at times george has been obsessed with
the way he looks
as a teenager he gained weight after he
broke his back he's gone to extremes to
control it started going into the
fitness industry in the fitness
community and i saw that all the guys in
that world were big muscular covered in
veins six packs and you know all that
stuff so i thought that's what i had to
adhere to that's where i needed to go
and then that kind of pursuit came from
there and that's when i took on like
disordered eating and exercise addiction
and i was training unbelievable amounts
of times and being incredibly
restrictive with how i ate and
eventually it led to these kind of like
suicidal behaviors and suicidal
ideations and
yeah let down this dark path
george has muscle dysmorphia he thinks
he's less muscular than he actually is
he says the picture-perfect culture on
social media has played its part and a
new report has found that a third of
young british men say they need to
change their appearance because of it
there's lots of pressure
from social media to trying to conform
to certain
stereotypes of an idealized beauty
and i think particularly in men this is
something that's a real challenge
because
um there's a we're probably a bit in a
way a bit less used to it than women are
um we're more recently exposed to these
kinds of pressures and regretfully women
have been exposing for a lot longer
but also there's very little movement at
the moment against
pressure on men
one surgeon says that pressure is
leading some to abuse steroids which can
cause breast growth as a result he's
performing hundreds of breast reductions
on men every year if you take a look at
what's playing right now what is it love
island right now if you turn it on every
guy on there has a six-pack his chest is
up to here pecks and everything are
blowing out of their shirts and so guys
are seeing this and they want to emulate
these are their heroes just like in the
80s when you had the you know sylvester
stallone and arnold schwarzenegger
that pursuit of so-called perfection is
something george may always need
counselling for
but he's in a better place now and
working to raise awareness of the
problem
lisa dowd sky news